F3: . We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David Pakman
many, many comments about the new David Pakman
show graphics and intro and outro music.
Let's listen to what the eggman had to say.
M12: Oh, my God. Is that new original music?
It sounds like Miami Vice almost.
You remember your original original
Nathan Michael Markazi doc seei right. That a
friend of yours. Anyway, I missed the original
music that you had the original original. But
every time you change it up I love it. Salom
brother was drinking a cup of water right now.
M1: All right Shulem. Eggman,
stay hydrated. Here's another comment about it.
M13: David, love the new intro man. I got to say a
The David Pakman Show.
F3: OK, and one more.
F6: Hey, David, this is Jeremy from
the Bay Area. Big fan of your show,
just wanted to provide some feedback on
a few things. I heard this show today,
Monday, the 15th. Number one, the sound the new
soundtrack is pretty cool. Sounds like a kind of
stranger things vibe. I feel like I'm in Khoosat.
M1: Exactly. And a lot of people saying that, but
many people very angry. And you know what's funny?
F3: Every time we've made a change over the past,
however many years, we've had like six or seven
times where we change graphics, theme music or the
set. Every time, as with anything, the people
who dislike it are most likely to contact us,
and what sometimes gets me is when
someone says, like offhandedly, like
you should change it back or I'm not going
to watch or listen anymore. It's like,
do you really think that we make these changes
so half heartedly that because of one email,
we're just going to change it all back? I get that
not everybody likes it. People are resistant to
change. People who dislike things are more likely
to write to you. But so far, I think our changes
have over the long term, improved the show. So we
are sticking with it. I know not everybody likes
it. I hope you will stick with the show as well.
If you stop listening to the show or watching
it because of the theme music. I don't know that
you really like the show that much to begin with
because you can just skip over it by skipping
forward 20 seconds. It's not a big deal, but
glad to hear that at least some people are liking
it. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
F7: Get instant access by becoming
a member at join Pakman dot com.